(upbeat music)
- Just like its name says,
NATO is a North Atlantic organization.
Here's the Atlantic,
and all of these blue flags
represent NATO countries.
The whole reason that the
organization came together
in the first place was to
protect against possible threats
from the Soviet Union,
and it's now protecting against Russia.
But lately, NATO has been
ramping up partnerships
on the other side of the
world in the Pacific,
and challenges from China
are the big reason why.
So how do NATO partnerships work
and what do they mean for both NATO allies
and potential adversaries?
Just weeks before Russia
launched its full scale invasion
of Ukraine, Presidents Xi
Jinping and Vladimir Putin
held a summit.
They released this joint statement
which made headlines around the world.
They declared that the friendship
between the two states has
no limits, and they said,
that the sides oppose
further enlargement of NATO
and call on the North Atlantic alliance
to abandon its ideologized,
Cold War approaches.
Russia and China see NATO
expansion as a huge threat.
(speaking foreign language)
But ever since Russia launched
its full scale invasion
of Ukraine, just weeks after
that statement was put out,
NATO has gotten both bigger and stronger.
Not only did Russia's
neighbors, Finland and Sweden,
move to join the alliance,
but some of the countries
in China's backyard
moved to strengthen their
relationships with NATO too.
I'm talking about the Pacific,
South Korea, Japan New
Zealand, and Australia.
While they aren't seeking full membership
they worry that what's
happening in Ukraine,
could also happen here in Taiwan,
the self-ruled island that
Beijing claims as part of China
and has threatened to take by force.
Taiwan is tiny,
but it produces a majority of the world's
advanced semiconductors.
Those are the microchips
that power our electronics,
our cars, our medical devices,
basically our whole lives.
And a war over Taiwan
could devastate economies,
no matter where they're
located in the world.
And that's why we keep hearing
the NATO Secretary General say this.
- Security is not regional,
security is global.
What happens in the Pacific
matters for Europe, for NATO,
and what happens in Europe
matters for the Indo-Pacific.
- For the past two years,
leaders of the so-called
Asia Pacific four have
attended major NATO summits
and events,
and those countries' militaries
have conducted exercises
alongside NATO.
These developments have
frustrated Beijing,
which says NATO is intervening
in regional affairs
and inciting bloc confrontation.
Now, NATO maintains that
it is a defensive alliance
and according to its chief.
- We will be remiss if we
did not expose the challenges
that China poses to our
security, to our values,
and to our interests.
- Experts say those challenges
aren't just in Taiwan,
they're happening all over the world,
like in Europe where Chinese
firms own stakes in ports,
roads and railways.
In Africa, where the Chinese have stakes
in critical mining operations
and technology infrastructure.
In the Arctic,
where China is developing gas projects
and transportation corridors.
And in space and cyberspace,
where Beijing has been advancing
its military capabilities.
Last year for the first time,
NATO's concerns about China appeared
in its main guiding document,
The Strategic Concept.
NATO says China is trying
to control key technology
and industrial sectors,
is using economic leverage to
create strategic dependencies
and is trying to subvert
the rules-based international order.
China says NATO's concerns disregard facts
and confuse right and wrong.
But here's the thing,
not every NATO member is on the same page
when it comes to how far
the alliance should go
to counter China.
If a NATO member like the
US gets involved in a war
in the Pacific, allies aren't
obligated to participate,
since Article 5 only
considers an armed attack
against one or more allies
in Europe or North America
as an attack against them all.
Plus different NATO
countries have varying levels
of interconnectedness with China.
So some are more hesitant than
others to ramp up pressure.
For example, NATO has discussed
setting up a liaison office
in Tokyo, but so far those
plans have been blocked
by French officials and
President Emmanuel Macron says
that enlarging NATO's
spectrum and geography
would be a mistake.
With or without physical offices,
experts say that NATO and
its partners could benefit
from collaborating on
things like cybersecurity,
space security, disinformation,
and even climate change.
But when it comes to a
potential war over Taiwan,
would NATO members and partners send aid
like they have to Ukraine
or perhaps get more involved in the fight?
Their possible role
remains a major question
and is something that the United States
is still trying to work out.
- The defense of freedom is not
the work of a day or a year,
it's the calling of our
lifetime, of all time.